hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of my form readers GT who was asking
about video marketing video blogs he's
expressed some frustration in watching
long videos that don't share any useful
information and don't have any text
underneath the video to be able to kind
of know what it's about he hasn't jumped
on board the video marketing bandwagon
yet it's not convinced that it could
work for his business and one of my
thoughts on it so GT maybe I'll be able
to convince you with this video we'll
see what happens first of all when I
include videos these short ask Kevin
videos I always below include some text
just to say what it's about and what the
question was you can kind of gauge if
you want to read it or not or watch it
or not and then for my longer videos a
famous entrepreneur transcript to allow
people to kind of get the points quickly
if they want or they can sit and watch
entire video do you have to be kind of
entertaining and have lots of useful
information from people to watch that
you know 9 10 minute videos as well why
I got in the video I think it depends on
your style I can answer question a lot
faster through the video than to write
up the text and people a lot more
forgiving if I make a mistake or the
words don't come out perfectly on video
it's a lot more forgiving because you
can kind of see me one on one then when
I'm writing you kind of have to have the
perfect answer well written when you're
creating blog content so that's one
reason but the other reasons why I
created it one I wanted to build a
better connection with my audience so a
lot of people were writing in asking
questions and I always answered them but
it's great to be able to see me so when
I first started my sight I didn't even
have my picture anywhere on and it was
kind of just showing the profiles of
famous entrepreneurs and we've evolved
that as people wanted to learn more
about me but it's a great way to be able
to connect with the audience on a big
scale people can watch your videos they
feel like they know me and kind of get
to see the face a lot of people also
visual learners they'd like to see the
person behind it and relate well to
videos so that's one reason why I do it
for answering questions I
used to just answer everybody by email
so they're writing with a question that
I've answered by email and that's great
for them but it doesn't help the whole
kind of entrepreneur community so I
created these videos to be able to help
everybody so it's great for me that I
can leverage the answer once and reach a
lot of people and it's also great for
entrepreneurs who are my customers i
guess to be able to get that knowledge
and useful advice i'm helping many
people instead of just helping one
person and then the third reason why i
really like using it is it comes up in
google searches so you too was obviously
owned by google google loves video and
for important keywords you can often
ranked much easier with the google video
through youtube then you can with
content so it's a great way to connect
with people it's a great way to get them
to know you better build a better
connection with your audience it's a
great way to reach more people than just
helping people one by one and it's an
also a great way to show up in search
engines and drive more traffic so GT I
don't know if I convinced you hopefully
you're thinking a little bit more there
are some struggles with video it takes a
long time to kind of get used to staying
in front of a camera and you know kind
of coming up with what you're going to
say and being comfortable there and you
might have to invest in some gear to
make it worthwhile for me I always I
started it very simply i used my my
little camera didn't go out and buy any
expensive equipment and he lighting and
he back dropped anything until I knew I
was committed to it they want to spend a
whole lot of money till I knew I wanted
to kind of stick with it so my first
videos might be really bad if you go
back and look at some of the older
videos or they're not they're not great
but people still like them and leave
comments and they enjoy them so that
that's good but don't make a huge
investment until you know your kind of
committed to it but encourage you to try
it out and see what the reaction is of
your audience and you just might get
hooked so I hope you guys enjoy GT I
hope that was useful for you as well if
you guys did please give it a thumbs up
please leave a comment I love hearing
from you it helps to make more these
videos every time I see when your
comments or thumbs ups like get
motivated to create more of these videos
so thank you for that and hopefully I'll
see you on the next episode
you